Here are both coordinate systems with the architect's scheme in blue, Minecraft
in red. We're in luck with the x axes, in both systems we know the x axes match.
Whatever happens with the y and z axes won't affect the x axis value. So in the
second system x will also be 10 . In the architect system, z goes up and in the
mine craft system y goes up. That's simple enough. The height of the point in
the architect system is 13. The height is still 13 in the mind craft system so y
will be 13. Finally in the architect system, y goes north and z goes south in
mind craft. The y coordinate in the architect system is 24. Since z is going in
the opposite direction. Z must then be negative 24. So the answer is 10, 13,
negative 24.